[Música]
el próximo domingo 4 de septiembre más
de 15 millones de chilenos van a decidir
en un plebiscito obligatorio si se
quedan con la constitución vigente de la
época de la dictadura de augusto
pinochet o aceptan una nueva carta magna
redactada por una convención
constituyente elegida por votación
popular con paridad de género y también
escaños reservados a indígenas las
últimas encuestas públicas apuntan que
la opción rechazo sería la ganadora con
una intención de voto del 56 por ciento
aproximadamente frente a la prueba que
estaría entre 4 y 2 puntos por debajo de
esta opción un plebiscito que tiene
además lugar tres años después de que
estallaran las mayores protestas
sociales en décadas en este país los
sondeos también muestran un amplio
porcentaje de indecisos del 10 al 15 por
ciento según analistas y académicos el
avance del rechazo al nuevo texto
constitucional se debe principalmente a
problemas en ciertos o contenidos sobre
esta organización del estado como lo
plantea la nueva constitución y no tanto
por los derechos que establece esta
nueva carta magna busca modificar el
estado actual
reducido también prioriza la inversión
privada y por un estado de bienestar con
una batería más amplia en los derechos
fundamentales saludamos entonces a
nuestro primer invitado al día el
guillermo holzmann analista político
internacional y profesor universitario
guillermo gracias por estar esta mañana
con nosotros en directo américa de
france 24 en su opinión cuál es la
principal razón de rechazar que rechazan
los chilenos a esta nueva constitución
yo creo que hay tres razones principales
la primera es insertables en la poule y
la publi nacionalista cuando sería
suficiente la multiculturalidad de la
pública nacionalidad como está planteada
en el texto propuesto que tiene que ver
con el autogobierno tiene que ver con la
autonomía tiene que ver con un derecho a
veto cuando se quiere hacer algo los
territorios que serían parte de la
herencia ancestral del pueblo originario
el segundo tema tiene que ver con la
desaparición del senado tiene hasta
ahora de bicameral la propuesta
constitucional señala que el senado
desaparece y reemplazada por la cámara
de regiones con menos atribuciones y eso
genera un desequilibrio en lo que es el
contrapeso que requiere una y también
romper la tradición política ción
interna y otra el sistema que es
importante con los sistemas de justicia
se establece un sistema de justicia que
es de una forma para pueblos originarios
bueno originarios en el caso de chile
representan el 12 por ciento de la
población
por lo tanto son 14 etnias hay iconos de
más justicia problema para ellos donde
el resto también cae eventualmente si
las faltas o delitos se cometen dentro
del territorio ancestrales tendrían que
entrar a jugar a jugarse en ese sistema
y un sistema de apagado barreto los
chiles ya que son los los elementos de
mayor avance que se practican para no
poder aprobar para rechazar justamente
la constitución por quien está en esa
opción claro guillermo porque el país se
llega tan dividido a este plebiscito que
van a votar los chilenos el próximo
domingo
el punto vista de la línea sorprendente
de esta división se haya dado
considerando que en el proyecto de
entrada unos 80 por ciento y eso
señalaba anteriormente un 80 por ciento
de la población tiene una nueva
contribución es decir hay una voluntad
única en mi transformación que está
acreditada no solamente por la solución
que se le da a la política institucional
de 2019 sino que ratificada en un
plebiscito en octubre año 2020 y sin
embargo el proceso de salida no aparece
como una solución a todo ello y eso
tiene al menos dos razones la primera es
que si bien es cierto la contribución
colocan nuevos temas que son necesarios
de poder abordarlo para una constitución
del siglo 21 la manera en que se
conformó la fórmula manera en que la
minoría es intensa que estaban de la
convención déjala fuera muchas
propuestas de en definitiva no no
satisface las expectativas de la
población e incluso tanto de
centroizquierda no no la satisface ahí
hay un grupo y no solamente ahora
rechazo sino que hay otro grupo que
vamos a aprobar para reformar esta idea
de que el contenido no satisface le hace
sentido incluso al propio gobierno
aunque ha dado las señales
correspondientes respecto a cómo va a
seguir el día 5 por lo tanto el día 4
hacer un proceso necesario pero de que
está muy claro que gane la prueba o el
rechazo del día 5 de presidente boris va
a tener que liderar las reformas y en
caso que gane la prueba o liderar un
nuevo caso ya vamos para allá para para
pero antes quisiera preguntarle cómo ha
jugado digamos la desinformación en todo
en toda esta campaña electoral para este
plebiscito del domingo realmente sí sí
ha habido la desinformación que han
denunciado también las después la
campaña de la prueba es sin
efectivamente hay una desinformación que
viene tanto del voto duro la prueba como
el voto nulo rechazo a que hay una
polarización donde la minoría intensa
que están en cada uno de los dos ejes
extremos ha ido planteando
ideas que son porque son falsas desde
por ejemplo que el mismo señalaba del
aborto se voy a hacer que el noveno mes
de gestación de que el tema la bebé de
arriba demostrar igualmente como si
garantizados a los demás está en que
muchas las cosas que hay aparecen desde
el aborto tipo de problemas de propiedad
privada que puede haber va a quedar
sometido a las leyes y eso es justamente
a la ley con puro simple cada cosa que
puede modificarse fácilmente según según
se tenga la mayoría del congreso pero
las féminas las de la desinformación es
un problema que ha gustado bastante todo
lo que es
el acceso al proceso que hemos tenido en
tirar la mente afecta en definitiva
digamos a una población que está
buscando y busca buscado es lo que ve
información que sean más adecuados a las
pueden superar todos ahora si guillermo
vamos al día 5 al lunes 5 de septiembre
si definitivamente gana el no apruebo
como lo están diciendo pues las
encuestas que una intención de voto más
de 54 por ciento pues de los chilenos
votarían el no apruebo cuál es el paso a
seguir definitivamente chileno tendría
esta nueva constitución cuáles pudieran
hacer las opciones que pueden manejar el
presidente gabriel boric que recordemos
que ese como que su bandera principal
de su mandato pues este es usted su
gobierno en este minuto hay
conversaciones y diálogos y me atrevería
a decir que negociaciones incipientes en
forma transversal para primero respaldar
el presidente boris independiente cuál
sea la opción que gane y gane la prueba
en la rechazó si gana la prueba el
presidente de tele quien lidera en un
proceso de reforma es importante a la
carta constitucional propuesta y eso
significa aunque al mayorías en el
congreso dado a realizarse el gobierno
no tiene el control del congreso no
tiene los votos necesarios para bolívar
para acometer ese objetivo si gana el
rechazo y técnicamente sigue vigente la
contribución pero hay completo impregnó
actuando transversalmente como en todos
los partidos políticos de iniciar una
iniciativa del presidente un nuevo
proceso constituyente no está claro si
eso va hacer una nueva constitución va a
ser grupo de expertos congreso una
mixtura lo que siempre claro y está
cortado ya es que este nuevo presidente
va a empezar de inmediato y que se va a
ratificar también con un plebiscito de
salida en ese sentido lo que hoy día
está en chile para el día 5 de
septiembre un apoyo transversal se
siente bonito para que con busquets y
broches o gane la prueba en el rechazo
en términos de poder entender de qué
sigue que decirle quiero a la nueva
constitución y aislando a la minoría
intensa o grupos más radicales que son
los que muchas veces se han impuesto la
agenda política respecto guillermo y no
dejar de lado ya para hacer un
comentario final antes de despedirlo a
estos indecisos que están también entre
un 10 y un 15 por ciento hay que ver si
pues ellos también pueden sumar los
votos para para el aprueba la
constitución es rápidamente 10
segunditos lo pudieran cambiar pudieran
cambiar su intención de voto que sigue
efectivamente podría cambiar su
intención de voto y como tú bien dice
que les dio por ciento de la población
la que sean indeciso o desideologizados
en definitiva pueden mover la boca de un
lado para otro considerando que el voto
es obligatorio y es ahí en serio no
sabemos cuánta gente va a votar y esto
tiene una incidencia ubica muy evidente
en todo ello